[Music]
there's a airplane orgy scene yeah you
guys are all on a plane there's a lot of
beautiful naked people you're and I'm
just I was looking at that scene and I
was thinking what's it like to be an
actor in that scene why wasn't I called
but especially was based on your memoir
thank you so I mean I that person
specifically yeah
airplane orgy but but yeah but what what
you know what was what was that scene
like I might romanticize again everyone
be fun has your reaction where they go
oh how was it was it so cool and the
only word I could use to describe it is
unhygenic it was the most unhygenic
scenario I've ever been in in my entire
life feels like an 18 hour day in this
enclosed airplane set and you know
there's a guy's balls like three
centimeters away from you you know and
usually when I have a guy's balls three
centimeters away from me I'm not an
airplane Conan I
we call that kind of joke is that
low-hanging fruit
all right now what beyond you I'm to one
here but the idea your cup he's naked
Red Bull and it's probably a hot you
know hot day and you know I my character
Donny was getting receiving oral
pleasure from a woman and you're there
all day for 18 hours and you're talking
and you know I you know she was really
nice she has two young kids
Trent transit you know she like her head
would be down there and be like you know
the transition from preschool to
kindergarten is just like so you know
and you're like yeah yeah yeah you know
yeah that does seem challenging you know
that you know and so you're just trying
to be as professional as possible horse
yeah yeah that's very strange
yes it was it was the strangest day yeah
now I hate now I don't want to see that
scene ever yeah yo Nick Rainey and we're
still in no time they were so in touch
but no now
I don't know what happened in this
interview got derailed no it actually
got much it's got great okay yeah now
there's a goldfish scene there's a
famous scene where you swallow a
goldfish because this is actually what
your character did in real life yeah did
you do that in real life you'd have just
it looks like you had to swallow a live
goldfish well everyone was so gung-ho
especially when you're working for
Martin Scorsese you're trying to make
everything as real as possible and I was
all for it you know and he asked me and
I said well you know the guy really had
a goldfish so I'll eat the goldfish you
know that's that I'll do that you know
and he came back to me he said well you
know PETA it's not gonna let you eat a
goldfish we tried and they're not gonna
really do it and said no yeah they said
no way Jose and so I don't think they
added the Jose but the guy calling the
hasp named Jose so they said no way hose
it so they they they said no and I go
well that's you know that's a shame you
know because I would have done it but
that's cool you know I respect the
goldfish life and honor and so I you
know so this is a 3-cent carnival
goldfish this is not like you know this
this thing's gonna pass away of natural
causes within the hour it leaves and so
I get there to shoot the scene and
there's three adult animal Wranglers
there's three adult gold.this this
goldfish has three people in its
entourage on set that is three more than
I have with me on seven things better
taken care than I am and I get it and
they go listen like real Stern with me
you can keep this guy in your mouth for
three seconds and then you guys spit him
back into water so we would shoot it and
I put the goldfish in and three seconds
later I'd have to spit it out into water
and so no joke this is not exaggerated
for storytelling purposes I can ask mr.
Scorsese or Leo to back me up
I put the goldfish in my mouth the first
take and it relieves itself in my mouth
I swear to you I swear to you
and he had been a PF Changs so it wasn't
no disrespect to be a change Pony no no
respect at all